what is happening in hollywood
that a guy that tough
will be on the street waving a gun
screaming they are trying to kill me
yeah what's going on
why is dave chappelle going to africa
why does mariah carey make a hundred
million dollar deal and take clothes off
on trl a weak person cannot get
to sit here and talk to you ain't no
weak people talking to you so what is
happening in hollywood nobody knows
the worst thing to call somebody is
crazy it's dismissive
i don't understand this person so
they're crazy that's [ __ ] these
people are not crazy they strong people
maybe the environment is a little sick
i i watched one of these nature shows
one time
and they were talking about how a bush
man
finds water
when it's scarce
and they do what's called a salt trap i
i didn't notice apparently baboons love
salt okay so they put a lump of salt in
a hole
and they wait for the baboon
the baboon comes sticks his hand in the
hole grabs his saw salt makes his hand
bigger and
he's trapped he can't get his hand out
now if he's smart all he does is let go
with assault
baboon doesn't want to let go of the
salt then the bushman just comes takes
the balloon throws him in the cage and
gives him all the salt he wants
and then the bat bone gets thirsty the
bushman lets him out the cage the first
place the baboon runs two is water
bushman follows them and they both drink
to their field
and that analogy i felt like the baboon
but i was smart enough to let go of the
salt
i got to tell you something and i don't
talk about it often have you ever worked
all your life for something and have it
not work out
that happened to me
it was tough
think about it
i was gone for 12 years
it's not a little bit of time
it was hell
i watched other [ __ ] that i
knew become very famous
i watched the world go on without me
i mourned the laws of it
and after a while
i didn't care
coming back was terrifying
i understand what i am
i really do more than anybody like when
they write about me in history i'll be
dead reading it like yeah i know they'd
say that
i swear to god this might be the noblest
of professions robin williams had a bar
that i loved he said comedy is the only
job you can have where you can use
everything you know
and that's true
you can use more than you know if you
use what you think
use it
don't be afraid
don't let these bitch-ass [ __ ] button
your lip
say it anyway
you can't you can't get unfamous you can
get infamous
right you can't get unfamous right
mom mom
mom
you have no idea what i put this woman
through
if you've just given birth to me that
would have been more than enough with
the fact
that she raised me and raised me well
he had a real oral tradition in my house
i knew the word griot when i was a
little boy agrio was a person in africa
who's charged with keeping the stories
of the village
everyone would tell agree over the
stories and they would remember them all
so that they could tell future
generations when they got old they'd
tell them to someone else and they say
in africa when a griot dies it's like a
library was burnt down
and my mother used to tell me before i
ever thought about doing comments she
said you should be a griot
and she'd fill me with every story of
black life you know she's educated in
african-american studies and she would
let me understand the context that i was
being raised in that i'm being raised in
a hostile environment that i have to
tame by the time i was 14 years old i
was in nightclubs
mastering an adult world it was
terrified
the crack epidemic was going on and my
mother would hear gunshots outside and
be scared to death maybe it's my son but
early in my career if you remember mom
you used to sit in the club with me
she'd do a full day of work you'd be
back there falling asleep just waiting
for me to go on she would watch my show
every night do you know how long that
car ride is home
how many of you have ever heard your
mother say [ __ ] jokes were a little too
much tonight son
i was a soft kid
i was sensitive i'd cry easy and i would
be scared to fist fight and my mother
used to tell me this thing i don't even
know if you remember but you said this
to me more than once you said son
sometimes you have to be a lion so you
can be the lamb you really are
i think that
america
needs a
honest discourse with itself
it's like the greatest country in the
world by default
you know i mean we could actually be
the greatest country ever existed
if we were just honest about
who we are what we are and where we want
to go and if we learn how to have that
discourse
things like racism are institutional
acts it's systemic
you might not know any bigots you feel
like well i don't hate
black people so i'm not a racist
but you benefit from racism
just by the merit of the color your skin
there's opportunities that you have
you're privileged in ways that you may
not even realize because you haven't
been deprived in certain ways
we need to talk about these things in
order for them to change i do the show
i walk down the street black people like
it white people the generations it
doesn't matter because it needs to be
talked about it's like the elephant in
the living room
that nobody says anything about so
when the bigsby thing came out there was
a lady from texas that called comedy
central
i mean family 100 times
she was furious with me
i wasn't mad at her for being mad at me
it's like okay that's good you know
not good that she's mad at me but
she's in time to her opinion
and maybe she's right i don't know i
just
thought it was funny that's what i did
i'm a comedian man that's how i look at
the world and that's that's what i'm
spitting out so
i don't i don't
i don't judge people or not like people
for thinking you know people that i love
tell me i go too far sometimes maybe i
went too far but i did it
[Music]
you know
and plus
the only way you know where the line is
is to cross it and i think that what is
life if nobody's crossing the line you
just want to try to be on the right side
of history and sometimes what's going on
in the immediate present is not as
important as
the long term the truth is permanent and
then everything else fall by the way
[Music]
i didn't want to say one thing today
just made me think about for all the
things that i've done
i'm most renowned for what i didn't do
i've made decisions in my career that
a lot of people have called insane
2004 had 50 million dollar deal on the
table
and in a crisis of conscience
flips the table over
and walked away
went to south africa
everyone said i was running away from
the money
that is not true
in fact i still want that money
the idea that i wanted to just share
with you guys this idea that sometimes
you you do what you think is best
uh whether anybody understands
or not
i heard a story about my father when
someone told me he used to do statistics
for a company in dc
the company he did statistics for
started doing business
with the south african government
so he quit his job
it's caused a lot of problems between
his him and his wife
it's hard for a man when he can't
provide for his family the way he wants
to
and he suffered through it and a
generation later when i had my crisis of
conscience i was able to go to a free
south africa
and get away from the heat
this idea that what you do in your
lifetime informs the generations that
comes after you is something like keep
thinking about something that is so much
bigger
than just ourselves and today i'm
standing in front of you guys and i know
you guys are like oh i know you're bored
but i see family of mine in the front
row that i some who i've never met
and i just realized how how all
all of us are
connected
that my great grandfather built
something more substantial than
buildings he built a community
and he built more importantly than a
community
he
he built a way
you know so i'm very grateful
uh
very grateful
hello police
um
he's standing be like so this is what
black people talk about
[Applause]
uh
i just want i just want i just want you
guys to remember you know that right now
there's this thing where where ethics
aren't what they used to be this idea
that
people are trying to replace the ideas
of good and bad
with better or worse
and that is incorrect
you gotta keep your ethics intact
because uh
good and bad is a compass that
helps you find a way and a person that
only does what's better or worse
is the easiest type of person to control
they are a mouse and a maze that just
finds the cheeks
but the one who knows about good and bad
will realize that he's in a maze
so that being said
i just hope that all of you guys
transcend whatever you see as your
obstacles
and that you live outstanding lives and
that you stay connected to your
communities because you have so much
power there and that you grow your
communities and you diversify your
communities and that you don't let
anybody
anybody tell you you can't
or to be afraid it's okay to be afraid
because you can't be brave or courageous
without fear
the idea of being courageous is that
even though you're scared you just do
the right thing anyway
so in 2004 i walked away from 50 million
dollars
and in november i made a deal for 60
million
so
although i am not the most famous
comedian of my time
i would like to know
what their great grandfathers did
i'm
i'm very proud today
thank you very much